thank you and I want to thank the
organizer the lineup is very impressive
i'm really looking forward to all of the
talks and so sir female laid out a
foundation for a lot of fair what i'm
going to talk about i'm going to ignore
basically the analysis i'm going to
focus much more on the interpretation of
a single cell a day line specifically
focus on a time serious single cell data
but before i start discussing networks
and regulation i want to talk about a
two issues related to the analysis of
time series data that I've been thinking
about and trying to look at for a lot of
time and at least a decade and and we
have some results recently I'm hoping
that other people will generate even
more result in that direction so time
series data the thing that we started
with and most of the people initially
thought about was gene expression data
primarily microwave now a lot of RNA
stake but although the last day I would
say two three maybe four years a lot of
other types of data measured over time a
lot of it because of the sequencing so
micronase obviously but also a lot of
epigenetic data is now measured over the
time a histone modification you can do
DNA's and so forth and protein levels
have been looked at over time but more
so now and also single cell analysis has
been looking at development as a time
series and there are two basic issues in
the analysis of time series data that
aim I think we have not addressed at
least not as much as we should have and
a few years ago I was asked to write a
review on on on using time serious gene
expression data and the editors really
wanted me to focus on the high life
where I called the high level analysis
of differentially expressed genes
clustering modeling and so forth and I
really wanted to discuss something that
I thought that people don't pay enough
attention in the sense that when you
work with a group of collaborators on
the analysis of time series will come to
you after they did the experiments and
then they tell you later the coastline
was really worried that we should be
involved much earlier so the thing I
wanted to discuss was how to design
these experiments and we went back and
forth and eventually we agree that it
won't be in the paper but it will be a
separate box which is where it ended up
so this is the sampling way but in that
paper we mentioned two issues that are
related to time series data the first is
VPS and the second in the supplement if
you look at time series data in public
databases you see that most of them on
the order of seventy percent and don't
contain repeats and the reason is clear
right if you do time serious you don't
have enough money to also do a second
and third day repeat for each of the
time points if you have two very very
little have more than two repeats per
time point now over the years I've been
contacted by a number of researchers
that were telling me look I submitted
this paper and the reviewer came back to
me and because I wrote some reviews
before and times this gene expression
the reviewer came back to me and told me
that you know it's unacceptable I did
I'm serious and I didn't do any repeats
you know I don't want to spend another
four months and tens of thousands of
dollars on this what can I tell him and
the best answer i gay I could leave me
look at this paper on this paper on this
Bible they also had time series with
with no repeats and you can say that's
pretty common but there was no or at
least I didn't think there was no
theoretical analysis that really told us
that you know maybe we shouldn't or at
least if there are constraints in terms
of budget which we always have maybe we
don't have to do repeats so that's one
issue the second thing is the sampling
rate now if you made a time serious
paper genomics Times newspaper again
this is more anecdotal than the previous
statement I made but fifty percent of
them don't even tell you why they select
at this point they said we sampled one
week one week very weak for and maybe
some people that domain no but most
people just the other fifty percent do
explain why they selected it and almost
all in all cases the explanation is
based on phenotypes so we know that day
for this marker is expressed and a day
20 the longest develop so that's why we
do this experiment now this is important
but obviously if you want to find out
why these markers expressed maybe you
want to sample a bit earlier to see the
networks that led to that and there was
no standard or no protocol to tell you
what is the best time for inst
sample now again if you just do gene
expression maybe that's not so bad but
now you do gene expression epigenetic in
proteomics and micro neighs and you want
all of them to be somebody at the same
points if you want to build model so
maybe there's a better or maybe we could
come up with better ways to
systematically decide wait to sample so
we looked at these two issues recently
and again these are things that I've
thought for a number of years now so the
first issue is whip-it and we can now
show theoretically that it's better to
sample at a denser rate and ignore the
reaping let's say you have a limited
budgets for example you everybody to do
20 experiments let's say in 10 hours
it's better to sample at the denser wait
so every half an hour for 10 hours
rather than doing a every one hour with
two repeats in the ability to
reconstruct the underlying expression
trajectories and again this only works
for expection trajectories and this only
works for gene expression where we are
sampling a lot of different signals at
once it doesn't work for individual
signal okay but this works and when I
say theoretically I mean that you can
always impurity go to papers and see
what happens when you remove some
samples and so forth but this doesn't
cover the entire universe we actually
can show now that for a specific type of
function piecewise linear function with
relatively small number of transitions
so if you only assume that gene can go
up and down and up and down maybe so not
too many which is actually you know it's
a constrained space but it's pretty
correct about characteristic of
characterizing the entire space of time
series data for those if you have a
reasonable error rate which is common
dense does better than repeat in terms
of error so this is dense of course
what's the sample once the error
increases then they both do more or less
the same but for a reasonable error rate
dense is much better and you can look at
a lot of things so this is one result
again very more theoretical maybe
justification but the other result is a
bit more practical and that's how to
design these some dis experiments in
terms of how do you choose the sampling
rate and a for some ways we had this
idea where you can basically do a very
dense sampling basically for example if
you look at 42-6 we are looking at lung
development and I'll talk about it in
this presentation if you do it there if
you look at six weeks of lung develop
you can sample very densely let's say
every half a day for relatively few very
relatively small number of genes you
don't want to do 80 or 100 RNA seek
experiments maybe maybe that's too
expensive but you are using you're
willing to use some bid a micro arrays
to do a very detailed sample of small
set of genes and it turns out that with
this subset of genes relatively small
150 200 genes which can be based on some
prior knowledge of what you know is
involved but I can also include a lot of
random jeans you can actually determine
a very good sampling rate for the rest
of the population and then the good news
at least from our point of view is that
the decisions you are making based on
the jail apply for the micro RNA as well
and the proteomic so basically you learn
the damping rates based on the jeans but
then you apply them to all other data
sets and it works reasonably well yes
bill quantification of gene products and
jeans is that right and so so what you
do is you select a subset so in this
case we started with 40 points you
select the subset of the points you can
spike the entire expression profile
based on that and then you compute their
own once the ones you didn't use so this
is happening you can think of it as held
out data okay so in all of them the held
out data is or basically the error is
under held out data the point you are
not completely confused about your
different sampling rates want to sing
the more densely than the other it seems
like okay you can see that it goes down
like the more points you should access
on points the same with a different
times the y-axis is pair a pair set so
basically the setting we are taking
office you have a limited budget you can
do ten experiments and your 40 days
where would you put those with your
budget right so as to select once you
selected the 10 points you reconstruct
the entire curve from that for the
entire 40 days but now we did sample the
other 30 points and you can compute how
much what's the error virtual
reconstruction error you get so this is
like in held outside okay so of course
to establish the method we actually did
over sample everything and then but this
is the end
okay so now let's go back to networks
and now assume that we know how to
sample everything is optimal and we get
that data okay so I want to talk about a
reconstructing networks in single cell
analysis and so we've been looking at
methods for integrating various types of
genomics data specifically time series
data with static data and again in many
cases the time series data has been gene
expression but you can also we've also
used over the years micronase mhm ipsec
time series data histone modification
time series data and the static data m
is primarily chips ecstatic information
motif information em sometimes protein
interaction information now in order to
integrate these two you want to have a
model that retains the dynamic aspect of
the data so you can actually tell what
happens at which time point but can
still use the static data to infer a
events of regulatory events and for this
we're using a method called hidden huh
oops input-output hidden Markov model
which aim is a standard hidden Markov
model includes a standard hidden Markov
model where states represent a basically
in this case gene expression you have
emissions for the genes but you also
have this input layer which is static
and you encode all the studying
informations for example the
transcription factor binding preferences
or a micro in a regulation in this
static data and what happens is that the
static data does not directly impact the
expression but it does direct the
transition probability so if you have a
gene that is expressed at some level the
probability that it will go up in the
next time point is a function of which
transcription factors regulated now once
it once you know that it goes up the
actual expression is coming from some
distribution so basically this the the
likelihood of this hmmm is very similar
to regular event but the transition
probability is not just a function of
the previous state like or the
transition of the hmm but also a
function of the static data now again
this was developed a few years ago and
other days we applied it to a lot of
different and others not just us to a
lot of different types of networks and
any talk to
everyone but now when you deal with time
series single cell data you run into
some new problems which is nice so one
of the mates so some of em introduced a
single cell data obviously when you do
these experiments you have a lot of
problems relating to how do you infer
the gene expression levels and so forth
let's assume that we know how to do that
em but one of the major but but if you
do the time series analysis you run into
the following problem so usually the
experiment starts with a set of cells
that are undifferentiated maybe stem
cells and it ends in what researchers at
least think is a differentiated set of
stairs where they can be a they can be
sorted by some marker and that was a
great comment before about the fact that
even though we know the markers we may
actually not know all of the molecules I
think with your comment that's a great
comment let's get to it a bit later but
for now let's assume that we know how to
solve the D cells at the end so we have
these cells of you and then you measure
a number of intermediate time points
let's look at one time point and you
want to create trajectories that link de
stem cells to these final or
differentiated cells and here's the
challenge if you usually you know the
starting point you know the end point
but you don't really know what should be
used to link the intermediate points and
once you take a sellout and you profile
it that's it you can see where it
differentiated to so it's easy to deal
with the first time for it easy to do
with us but the intermediate time for
each other more interesting very hard to
associate with specific trajectories and
if you want to learn now models of a
self a decision or regulatory networks
that impact cellular differentiation we
need to be able to create a trajectory
or determining cell assignment to this
trajectory so that's a major problem
that people have been looking Oh noticed
over the last year i would say m m a
right over the last year and won an
additional problem is the fact that the
time in which you measured the cell does
not necessarily correlate with the
function of the cell what do I mean by
that and this actually has been shown
nicely experimentally so it could be
that even though to say it could be that
even though we are measuring cells at
maybe three different time points some
cells at the last time point in this
case let's think of lung development so
we're measuring at day 14 day 16 day 18
some cells a day 18 I really still
undifferentiated and they belong in some
sense of the intermediate cells but they
are mixed in with the differentiated
cells and that's to definitely for a in
vivo development and it's even more true
for individual studies for example
people have looked at the blood on my
Oblast differentiation so it turns out
that even if you do a time series the
one thing is how do you connect these
cells along the trajectories and second
do you really trust the time of the
experiment to do any of these
assignments so for example are you
always assigning the second cells in the
second time point intermediate or maybe
to that and these are two issues that
people have identified or looked at and
those two major approaches to dealing
with this and this came of course in the
last year is a pretty new studies and
the first approach set of approaches and
again I don't want to sound criticizing
they looked at slightly different types
of data sets but basically they
completely ignore the temporal aspect
basically if you select a few sample to
a cells at different time points they
ignore the time and they created what
they called pseudo time so basically
they order the cells based on just on
gene expression alone and some of these
allowed for branching some didn't allow
for branching and that's a separate
issue but they looked at that they also
i should say used and again i like the
point that surfing made these methods
use deterministic approaches for
computing the similarity they looked at
it and dimensionality reduction using
maximum minimum spanning tree so there
are some issues we led to stochasticity
that's a separate issue the second
approach was completely ignore the
expression and just believe the time so
this is the time again that doesn't
solve the project I problem by the case
that allows you to orderly and both of
these may be problematic as M have I
think I try to explain and of course all
of the method so far have only relied on
the gene expression they didn't
integrate other types of data
for example transcription for
interaction so we asked whether we can M
improve some of these by coming up with
a new model that takes into account both
the time and the expression and allows
for stochasticity in both measurements
so one approach we are looking at is a
hmm different from the previous one I'll
go back to that later but this is a
standard hmm except for a one thing the
the emission and transition
probabilities are linked over time in
the sense that they are auto regressive
or Kalman filter a generated from the
previous time point so each of these
states is basically a collection of
cells or represents a collection selves
at a specific time point and so they
have an emission probability related to
the gene expression n to the time so
cells from the first time point usually
have a time point from the first time
that they can also have time points from
the second time point because of this a
synchrony and also they have these and
also they have this gene expression
trajectories ok so this is standard hmm
in terms of emission but the transition
probabilities are slightly different
than regular hmm first of all we fix the
model or we look at slightly a number of
different model and and we have
transitions but sometimes we only allow
transition from a previous state but the
mean values for the expression in time
are evolving from the previous state in
other words you have a Kalman filter
model for the expression or
autoregressive model for the expression
of the next time step conditioned on the
previous on the expression in the
previous time set ok so this mean
expression of course is a function of
the cells assigned but it's also a
function of the previous state in some
sense you assume that gene expression
and time are highly correlated between
consecutive States now again if you do a
time series analysis in boxes that's
clear right because the next time point
is but in this case we don't just need
to associate the expression we also need
to associate to assign cells to these
states so if you don't require it you
can get very coherent states but they
can be all over the place
of the relationship so you need to
somehow constraint this transition for
bills and na i'm not going to go into in
france and learning learning in this
case involves a nested AEM because you
have in addition to the regular vm you
need another forward and backward to
estimate the probability the expression
based on the autoregressive model and
then you do the regular am learning for
the assignment and for learning the
parameters we'll skip that but i'm going
to talk about in applying this to some
data and specifically the data i'm
looking at again lung development data
that's something we've been working with
collaborators few years now a.m. and the
original if the experiment was done two
years ago and they looked at three
different time points in 14 days 16 days
and 18 days and again measured a number
of different cells of course but the
focus was on the last time point so
basically identify the head markers for
these a last time point of the cells
that were assigned to the last time
point a lot of them roughly eighty
percent displayed known markers twenty
percent did not display any of the known
markers and so these were assigned by
the researchers to a new cell type which
is called by phone or by potential
progenitor basically this is a new cell
type that was discovered by these
experiments because it didn't match any
of the new cell phones okay so let's see
what happens when you try to analyze
this data with different methods so this
is the first muscle this is the monopole
that i mentioned it doesn't use time at
all so it just takes the expression and
tries to figure out the branching
process based on that and it doesn't
talk with and again not surprisingly it
doesn't use the expression here's what
you see this is the first time point the
the purple one then you have a branch
for the second time point and the cell
type point so you don't go really from
them intermediate they just clustered
someone on their own there's no real
trajectories and the third time point is
also so each color here is a different
type of cell you can see they're broken
up almost randomly in terms of you know
one is the majority of the cells are
here but then you branch into a
different egg again this is biologically
doesn't make sense that's actually not
true biology and then one of the major
reasons why this fails is because
there's no I mean just based on the gene
expression you can't probably in fear
please note with this method this is the
results that we get using this hmmmm
model and in this case I didn't
mentioned but of course the hmm the work
resented it is applied to a specific
model so what we do is and you can do
different search methods but right now
what we do is we look at the number of
different possible models and the nice
thing is that you are looking at a very
small number of time points of the space
of possible models is pretty small and
you compute a VI Cisco and then you can
compare different models and in this
case the model that was selected by J
hmm is this model which is basically am
starting with one with just one cell
type then two and then four and we
actually tried I don't have it here we
also tried something that splits to five
but it's called actually much lower than
the four model so in other words the
model that we have claims that you have
this branching process so and again I'm
not showing you the seller summer i'm
just showing the branching process but
if you look at the cell assignment you
see that each of the four different cell
types that were known is associated with
the terminal brunch and again this was
answered by so the fact that it is it's
at least to some extent a biological
validation that the model makes
reasonably sorry fight finding so you
can see each one of these is associated
with the tunnel punch there's only one
set of cells that is not associated with
the terminal by a with the terminal a
state and that's these new type of cells
in fact not only are they not associate
uniquely with with a specific type of
cells a lot of them are associated with
the earlier time points but this
basically model claims now and this is a
biological finding that these by
potential progenitors are not really a
new type of cells these are just earlier
cells that have not fully differentiated
and in some sense they actually should
be associated with the previous time
point and if you look at the biology
behind this you see that this is
actually something that you can explain
or disagrees with some other models
where you have a number of cells that
can differentiate later to a different
type of cell and not in this case 81 or
82 the two primary a bit epithelial
cells and they don't have to actually be
fully differentiated at the last
so again if you just use time you get
one observation which is we have a new
type of cell if you just use expression
it's very hard to be contrite but if you
combine both of them you get models that
at least make sense and the other things
you can do with it let's skip to the
next day okay so once we have this a but
let's go back to the models once we have
this we can actually now learn a
regulatory model how do we do this so
again we start with the set of cells and
let's say we have some assignments of
the cells to different states based on
the initial model that we learned for
example based on this hmm so now once
you have this you see that these
terminal States actually using the same
intermediate step cells so both of them
are the progenitors of these two are
these cells and the progenitors of these
are these cells so now basically you
have a new trajectory of cells or a new
time series basically that you can use
to learn and with with any of the
methods you like to learn Goulet or
networks from time series data again we
like to use our method but anybody can
use any method there's a few other
things you want to do and so this is for
example one of them you can derive a
regulatory networks based on these three
models for this specific type of cells
by just taking the side the cells that
are signed and treating it like a
regular bulb expression data set now
because now we assume that the cells are
more homogeneous in terms of the
different state there so she do it and
it's the seraphs you mentioned it you
have to be a bit careful when you deal
with a tie with a single cell data and
one of the major problems is the dropout
issue so dropout means that genes that
are expressed at low levels can be
completely missed so it's like almost a
binary signal whether because of
amplification and other things if you
have a probabilistic model that doesn't
take that into account you can very
negatively affect the association of
cells with state because if you have
some probability and it's 0 basically it
can be very bad so this is something you
need to deal with and there are ways to
we look at in this case specifically I
looking at mixture probabilities for
emission that these are not not
necessarily very complicated and right
so we have an iterative assignment of
cells like we did before another thing
we are variant
studying is identifying not just the
models but what are the transcription
factors that differentiate the different
models why is that important because if
you look at self and determination you
want to explain why some cells become
this type and once I another cells
become this type for that you wanna
identify what other regulators or the
key regulators that differentiate the
two and if you know that you can
actually treat the cells or maybe knock
out these and see what is the outcome
that you get once you do these
perturbation experiments and if you're
right maybe you can actually know you
can actually show that these are the
ones that lead and we have some way of
determining significance for these M
transcription factors based on how well
they explain or how well genes that are
regulated by them I'll differentiated
between the two models okay so this is
something we apply to the same data set
that I mentioned this long data set and
you learn in this case four different
models one for 81 cells and this by the
way this method allows you to be
assigned cells so initially we assigned
cells just based on expression in this
method we use expression plus other
information in this case transcription
factor so you may actually get slightly
different results we have allowed so the
method is allowed to be assigned cells
to state and it turns out but but in
general it finds more or less the same
result we have 11 terminal model for 81
cells one term in another one for 81
because one of them was very small but
the important thing is did the a BP
cells are divided between the 8080 to
model and 81 model so the same
conclusion m you can also find as i
mentioned transcription factors that
distinguish the different cell types in
many of these transcription factors are
known and you can explain why they are
high in one type you can actually
explain why they are high in one type or
they are actually known to be involved
in one type of cell but not in the other
and vice versa so in that case that's
some validation that the method does
identify not just a models but also
transcription factors that drive that
and lasting and we looked at some
external validation and again those
different things you can do it's very
hard to do this in vivo studies and this
is in vivo data in terms of perturbation
so we took a much easier approach i
would say in some sense and we looked at
some transcription factors that came up
in the models in this
in the 81 model in the first jewel
family but did not come up when you do
the balcony so if you take all the cells
put them together you don't see a unique
pattern for the force in June a the
first in June transcription factors for
this specific system only when you
separate it out computationally to the
different models they start to appear as
key transcription factors in one model
but not in the others so basically what
this is is a prediction based on a
specific type of model but not as bug
and fortunately we were working with
collaborators that had an IPS system set
up to express specific types of lung
cells disqus um so the experiments were
done in mouse the collaborators had
human myself and it turned out that a
this specific transcription factors that
we identified in the 81 cells indeed our
differentially expressed and their
targets and so some these are some of
the possible factors and some of the
targets are differentially expressed in
this IPS system are in as part of
development so again it's very hard to
find them when you open bar cell but
when you open single cell it becomes
easier I think the ultimate experiment
which is very hard to do but we're
hoping to do is to do some knockout of
perturbation and see that we really get
much fuel types of cells from the ones
that the transcription factor is
believed to regulate okay so that's it
i'm i think single-cell a data in the
under-18 it's very similar to issues we
discussed we have been discussing for
almost 20 years now how do we find
differentially expressed genes how do we
normalize and so forth but how do we
identify time series or how do we modify
search data on the one and these are
seems to be very similar Asia but on the
other hand they have I think a new
dimension or some new challenges that we
didn't have with the previous type of
data and I think they provide or they
can enable us to answer a lot of
questions that are very hard to answer
when using both data so i think it's an
exciting time actually it has been
exciting time for the last 15 years in
this area but it remains an exciting
time so with that I want to as a thank a
lot of my students and collaborator
we've walked in dream
the years on the single cell data we are
collaborating with a group at BU and
that's it thank you need a man around
here Colin extension to the hmm so the
generative process is that you have
basic regenerative processes single cell
differentiation right so you have a set
of cells a set of stem cells right and
due to either external cues or some
internal cues they start to
differentiate into more than one a type
of cells now the idea is that even
though they differentiate most of the
genes are not affected by this Q few of
the genes are affected most of the genes
are not affected so if you have cells
that are coming from very again depends
on the subway but if you have cells that
are very closing time you expect the
gene expression Patman to be pretty
similar to each other and also you would
like or you would expect their time to
be more or less similar now there could
be things that you know you measure
something very late which just took a
long time so this is the generative
process your order is the gene
expression changes relatively slowly it
does change but it changes relatively
slowly and consecutive time points
should be highly correlated
imported assumption about expression
changes because of the slow it's not
affecting your difficulty with June fast
safe because those are immediately other
genes and about really really quickly as
it cool down also very good yeah great
actually great person and great comments
0 so gene and forth I'll transcription
factors transcription factor especially
that the a key transcription factors
some of them are activated earlier and
some are actually even prescription they
activated right so you don't even see
them activated and the other those
little lines of thought in the big
community about how to model
transcription factors in studies one
line says let's look at the expression
pattern and see if they are active then
we say Mao if they're changing we can
say the our team we take a different
approach we only in further the
transcription factor is active based on
its targets so it doesn't matter how
long it is from our mother how long
journey enforcer app as long as the
targets are up for enough time we can
identify them but yeah it's a good point
finders that correctly you are getting
different networks for different yeah
well we are getting different a the
overall network so different they shall
they show the initial time they can
share substructures but the overall
networks are different yeah because I
guess some of these sir times is part of
this development process well one of
them amount yeah network separate
networks stopping at 5.0 so again the
question is what do you call separate
networks so we have let's say we're four
different or in this case with I know if
you can see here
you can see that these two look pretty
similar initially right and these two
maybe this at least these two look
pretty similar initiative right the
reason is that we believe that the cells
that lead to but but at the end they
look slightly different maybe you know
this hazardous big job here which
doesn't so what happens is that yeah
they share components earlier on but
these components do not necessarily have
to be shared in the internet'll so you
can have subsets that are similar and
substitute or not sinner because of the
way the hmm is computed later time
points can have impact on some earlier
time points as well so you can have
slight but but in general the Oh again
if this was longer they definitely share
a lot of the initial structure and and
that's by design so yeah we you're right
it's the same process